[Music]
what is going on there citizens of the
reject Nation it is time for the Gen V
almost almost the point for the Gen said
it again gen V Episode 2 today if you
didn't catch our reaction episode one
that is up here on the channel thank you
guys so much for being here John how are
you I am generating lots of excitement G
it's getting better Coy I'm generally
thrilled to be this vivacious ly intact
oh my God how vicarious of you ladies
and gentlemen be sure to leave a like on
this video that'd be very much
appreciated be sure to subscribe click
that notification we get notifi when
reaction where episode 3 is up here on
the channel I also want to say thank you
to all who have been buying RR apparel
www. reation shop.com got my sister to
be the head designer for us we have this
shirt who influences the influencers I
feel like that's geny appropriate we
also got this t-shirt that t-shirt this
new one that we launched this week for
them Star Wars funds and another one and
then we got a whole bunch more it's one
of the best ways to support the channel
thank you guys so very much especially
for videos like this which are likely to
be demonetized due to what the content
is happen with all of our episodes of
the boy season 3 lastly full length 3
and watch along sing with your own copy
of gen V available for super sexy
rejects over our patreon page cover
several shows exclusively over there
reaction highlights and watch alongs
included let's get into it ladies and
gentlemen
[Music]
but I'm a looky L we're looking right
now black
noir Breaking
Bad I mean
yeah nice Metallica
flip I think this show has a little bit
more of a sadness to it too there's a
lot of Sorrow it's not gleefully
malicious it's sadly malicious yeah the
kids are sad man like there's a
permeating sense of loneliness that's
always there
God dang it's night time how long they
been cleaning this up I mean that's a
big mess I have $5 million worth of
Golden Boy merch
hey Golden Boy suffered a full psychotic
break was also a chronic drug user thank
God Andre Anderson was there to stop him
classic superhero story of course A
Psycho Killer but Heroes rise look for
the helpers all that [__] and we're also
throwing together a Brink Memorial Galla
should be a nice little Le
fine they're the one who actually fought
Golden Boy Oh a bender Asian with
pronouny great idea Kyle try selling
that to Dallas in Fort
Lauderdale oh boy this feels like
necessary viewing to complete your boy
experience yeah I immediately take away
one of my points last episode if the
wood is exposed we all have a big
potentially fatal problem when 400 kids
learned they weren't gifts from God but
their parents drugged them with compound
V infants I barely had any did I wow you
had one tonight good stats excellent
barely also good point Ashley you
okay I wasn't totally sure what you're
into so I packed the bong she's not used
to being even comforted like that or for
someone forgiving her I am with you you
pick any of it a should we do all of
it yes I promised myself I'd keep my
head down work my ass off no room for
anything else man she was at school for
24 hours it's first day tomorrow it's
not even the first day orientation time
damn I wondering if had shown into
classes but nope can I get a
selfie uh
no jeez up my friend Marie Moro say
what's up who are you
shs I'm live here top 10 top 10 what I
mean you don't have your push
notifications turned on I don't have a
phone okay Nolan
yeah the first freshman ever to be
ranked in the top 10 yo damn this is
like college football I am Jose
Mourinho his death is paying off this is
conflicting
five the attention you can get off of
the death of a loved one it really just
how do you make it about you that CL
ultimate clout Chase tell you I created
this channel I'm just waiting for it one
of you one of us that's why you grew out
so many of
us be right back I already have the
thumbnail way more reject lose ready to
launch you seen that Scream
[Music]
movie CH he's got the right
idea she got the right idea influencers
they're the best yeah the Real Enemy I'm
sorry I know what Brink meant to you I
don't know why Luke did
it red hat good guy something funny
Rufus Rufus no no dumb [__] was it about
Golden Boy I want to hear I said what
some guys will do just to get away from
Kate ouch buy yourself a nice Lille
Slugger and swing that bat as hard as
you can into your nuts every hour on the
hour and every time you swing jamanji
[Laughter]
my soul sister sorry I me no disrespect
to you your community I'm Jeff is his
name crutches director you are not easy
to get a hold of no I'm sorry about the
crutches tripped on the red carpet at
paleyfest this is for you haly Center
why is this happening rankings are based
on a careful analysis of talent skill
brand awareness and social mention you
[__] own Twitter right now # black magic
no this show needs to be updated it's
called
X that's right formerly Twitter ad First
National interview had to rescue Master
boox 20 from that nut job allow to Los
it before my first national interview
and here you are I want to push you
around Big Year Smashbox 20 huge Luke
gave us what got you here look after
your mother died I wanted to crawl into
a bottle of Mallen and stay there but we
push through no matter how hard it gets
you're going to be a better polarity
than I ever was is this an actual
wholesome relationship with a parent I
don't trust it wholesome disregards one
person's death I have an interview yeah
one-onone with Haley Miller Jeff didn't
tell
you hay Miller's going to ask me
questions everybody cannot wait to hear
from you and Andre you guys are heroes
So currently we're testing the guardians
of gulan guardians volume one it's just
all written out you got to memorize your
little brain you got
it isn't this the
[Music]
life a take the stage I want to see
these characters
descent well it seems like every time
she levels up it comes with great
traumas and I will still take the photo
that's why you say yes to give the
illusion of choice did you get that from
your dad did l say something to you
about my dad he just said the woods
before he died he said uh your dad has
it oh don't understand how the most sane
person that I have ever met just loses
his [__] and I'm the only one curious
about it well good luck with
that I am not curious he tried to kill
me that [__] at the club Brink was going
to expel me for it did you know that no
I would never ask for anything you don't
have to you have your dad and half the
school ready to cover for for you yeah
you're way better off right now than me
I'm sorry your friend is dead and I'm
sorry Brink is dead but leave me out of
it interesting Dynamics what a great
monologue cuz that's what a tricky Arc I
just want everyone here to know that I
know we all experience a great our
director man teaching theater class
welcome to acting for auditions yes
acting for self tapes coming next week
with a prepared scene because I want to
see what kind
of Cl
yes I'll be with what did that mean it's
the real the sniff that got me it was
the sniff it's just really savoring the
moment M hey suest
right ug
sorry dude Liam you piece of [__] let me
guess you made this poor girl get small
cuz that's the only way your looks
big
what that's exactly what happened that
dude he bangs everyone to compensate for
his tiny thimble I should have warned
you I'm sorry anyways want to be
partners up now I'm so worried for her
the system is going to eat Emma no she's
guys if there's anything you know about
this
world people who deserve to end off well
definitely good
there Professor brinkhof died the same
way he taught a hero nobody could
possibly replace him so I will all right
but we'll also get into the intersection
of superpowers and mental health which
so she got into the
class yes sorry I'm late I'm Dean Shetty
it's a pleasure to meet you likewise
we're letting Miss Moro audit the junior
year classes what you and Andre did it's
obvious you belong
here I've been saying
so villainous it ever occur to you while
you're getting it and I'm not cuz Bender
doesn't play in Jacksonville you
rejected me from this school I don't owe
you or anyone anything everyone just
needs to leave me the F alone whoa nope
you're getting interviewed by Miller
right just tell her the truth about what
I did that's all they gave me a script
slipping in go off script whatever story
you tell them they have to run with
that's what Brink always said it's a
nice detail with the Dual necklace yeah
noticed that for the first time the
chain in the pearls as a congresswoman
from Brooklyn after brutally murdering
an innocent protest homelander woo
parents of Luke rean better known as
Golden Boy barricaded themselves inside
their home now their attorney says
they're simply in mourning but then why
are they
hiding what do you think he'd do he
wouldn't stop till he about to the
bottom of it let's go a montage where's
that guy with the baseball bat and
whacking his nuts he's yanji
once say now it's about time there he
was good call did you think I picked you
cuz you get tiny M no no I picked you
cuz you're great cuz I want to learn
from you uh but me you kind of want to
see her get tiny a little bit it's like
when you hang out with an adult actress
you kind of want to see their video
you're
curious no way I'm typ casting you
unless you like getting small I'm always
small that's my secret cat small heart
can never get
big hurts I mean I'm losing the name on
the back of my teeth what do you mean
sorry nothing I'm just okay
no you want to let her in I love the
relationships cuz she's actually
interesting and not just like surface
they could have made the popular girl
that I purge to get small
like
yeah you're not getting small for this
scene who do you want to play Queen mave
then you're playing Queen mave my muse D
hope she doesn't betray her before I was
a dean I was a behavioral psychologist
specializing in superheroes it's
difficult for you you to open up because
when you lose control tragedy your mama
dad which wasn't your fault wow you are
a
professional you clamp up and you push
everyone away how I doing am I warm I
cold I'm not here to do keg stands or
get high or get in touch with my
feelings about my past your tears are
not giving it away oh know why do you
want to be a hero to help people and the
view from Seven Tower doesn't hurt
because you view yourself as a villain
why really my sister she got adopted I
don't know where maybe with enough money
I can I can find her uh she'll see that
I'm not a monster MH we could be a
family again get your validation from
your sister if she accepts you then but
you need to have self-acceptance man I
like you Marie I just want to help you
what a hot ass
Dean SL psychologist you guys see my
therapist whoa I would tottally my
therapist go just distractingly hot can
we all get a session going I go to
therapy every day now be so healed a
sorry guys can't make it got therapy I
mean I get it Paul I'm Greg that's my
day whoa every refen is in there this
Cameo oh
my easy Sam every time you try to leave
you hurt yourself sure
[Music]
spinal
tap whoa
dude where is all this stuff they
cleared it out is that what they did not
here no it's all just here but
invisible it smells like bleaching here
why would they do that the is going on I
don't know but we should stop asking
immediately oh that's how she betrayed
oh that is cruel wow dude immed like
star of Fun Size with Little Cricket has
to throw up to get tiny wow patriarchy
makes women Chase unattainable beauty
standards and I for one am [__] sick
a fainting help oh dude what if you lit
your tail oh naughty sexy like it's a
is this an only fans
mhm yeah baby Nancy ring that [__] but
the patriarch is really forcing some
[__] you know why would you do that
Nancy re was it a secret of course it
was a [__] secret sorry but you never
said that I just I thought you had an
experience that could help other girls
wow security cameras
melted did you do that no I know
something High did your dad has it this
this
security it's a clue but I think he hit
something in
here oh that's good that he spok in
Clues H the riddle really helped not had
to say was Statue dad statue it's hidden
in this Cod piece check the
d of that's how you know if Spider-Man's
real or not you got to check the
shading
see iPhone
16 if you're watching this okay I know
this sounds crazy but they have my
brother he's not de he's underneath the
scop they call it the woods it's like
this up hospital or something oh no
Brink is a part of this I'm going to go
in there right now I'm going to make him
give me my brother back if you're seeing
this I guess things got pretty
Fu and then some schizophrenia or some
[__] right he died in that facility that
um some something Grove unless he didn't
that sounds insane
right oh
[__] interview um go I got to get a few
hours sleep anyway my head kills from
all the pushing up and doing lately no I
I should stay because we need to figure
out everything that we can about
seriously it's not just your dad I don't
get how you guys can push all that to
the side right now what you just learned
yeah they both have super
compartmentalization just us
we knew we had to stop Golden Boy before
he killed more innocent people oh that's
mean that's just not true what about
London's character is she gonna do you
think she vouches is she going to do her
own thing Ah that's what I was wondering
if she was going to say Jordan Lee
careful Jordan's the one who really
Golden Boy can you trust the MUA right
now please don't die to this episode
yeah I like you
Woods hey such organization on these
folders make Woods great
again
who hey he's he's that
boy
screenshot there you
go
Boogie
oh
my oh no no no
no that the
computer damn you got here just in time
boy Marie Haley Miller oh wow hey she
looks like a fox person oh no will this
be a commentary of some kind doubted it
though Co what don't worry there's not
going to be any gotas we won't mention
your sister wow
oh what do you mean I thought you knew
I'm sorry we invited her to comment
wow you know where she is not really we
just found an email can I have
it what did annab Beth say she said she
didn't want anything to do with you this
is great great information to learn
before getting interviewed seconds
before in a murderous frenzy
charging and it was just
you I mean this should be more motiv
just do whatever you want yeah that's
what I'm thinking she's going to just go
for the seven don't cut away from her
face she's either going to crash and
burn or become the black
Starlight oh boy yeah exactly they show
knew what they were doing I knew I had
to stop Golden Boy there it is before he
killed more innocent people
yes Jordan give
in damn it you find that kind of Courage
I love it you're watching the
development of how they become this
we're seeing the origin of characters we
hadn't met yet but care about like the
seven God I haven't been so flushed in a
scene like this in a
while I just is London gonna come the
villain though like does
Jordan oh man just ask for another
interview just go back vodka I think she
was her
roommate
oh answer that sincerely you know what I
was
focused I mean we're all roommates with
VOD coy
some of us have some rough years
John clearly you still
are oh
[Music]
man everyone feeling small biman cutting
parallel with powers is like
so depraved sad did you know about my
sister of course not come
here this is how you take control yes
use her how do hug her eyes open that's
what I'm talking about you know what
doing you know what you're doing no no
no the strings rise no her your product
fought now
I'm there's a lot you can learn from
[Laughter]
VA what's going on can I help you all
good campus security nothing to worry
about campus
SWAT oh dude
why I wouldn't go that way yeah dude
[Music]
no oh Sinister DS have a wider range of
hearing than us like
dogs turn it off Bob first you're going
to get this flashlight nice and wet with
youring
mouth then I'm going to stuff it right
up your tight little Chocolate Starfish
woo until you see God until you see the
hot dog water you want to [__] give this
flly oh
my this this is the beginning of A
Beautiful
[Applause]
[Laughter]
Romance I'm
totally oh the kids are not all
right k k
so this is a very good
show yeah it is yeah this thing go hard
yeah man that was really good
yeah so soothing so comforting I'm on
side guys yeah no no no no I think
[Music]
um they created them
so the property they own them um and
pressure you know creates diamonds
saying you want compound that country
you got to embrace capitalism you got to
lean in just get stronger or else you
can complain about it or we can use your
complaints to just make more money where
are those bootstraps you're pulling up
from come on you know get after
it it's like the boys great commentary
for a show that Amazon gets to greatly
profit from guys oh they win because
they're like they can just punch whoever
they're just punching and profitting
just punching you want to make fun of
this the writers really win the strike
come
on they fought for what 0.008% income
who gets the other 90% of profit off of
us see this commentary Bezos that's what
I'm talking about who's demonetizing
this video a big
Corporation one of the biggest in fact
John what' you think I am gripped
continually by the series it's yeah this
fascinating blend of you know all the
shock and schlock that you're used to
from the boys but yeah as you guys have
both pointed out with a greater sense of
melancholy being lost in this world and
and being point that out caught up in
yeah just these systems that feel so
much bigger than and they're really
great at like even though the boys also
has that in that you know you think
you're oh you're part of the seven
you've made it you know you're going to
be a big fish in a small pond or
whatever you know this feels
exponentially more you know Koi
pond uh yeah and just yeah the the
messiness of the choices I think is
really compelling maddening at times but
in a good way in a dramatic way and uh
and yeah I it's hard to watch a show
like this in some aspects because you
sit here and you endear toward
characters and and it it's always a sign
of something that's working when it
breaks your heart when people you know
make the wrong choice go with the
selfish option or you know cover
something up when they should just be
vulnerable about it and to watch as you
know all these Predators desend upon
these poor kids you know who are just
trying to do right and find their lot in
the world uh yeah I'm quite compelled
what did you guys think sure Coy has
like a minute of thoughts why you take
it away Coy with your
your
brevity what I'm known for uh I really
love how the characters that have had
like the least amount of screen time
keep pulling me towards them uh like the
the character played by London Thor the
Jordan Lee I think the name was um I'm
so curious whether they become a villain
whether they like find some sort of
Justice whether they like get to
actualize or not and I really like that
the show is able to juggle like eight
leads and I'm still curious about people
that have only had a few minutes of
screen time and I think that's really
great world building because it'd be
easy for a show to give you a seven and
to give you a certain amount of leads
and the first episode The or uh but this
one uh I you know I didn't expect to
lose the lead Golden Boy literally The
Golden Boy in the first episode and I
really didn't expect this to take so
many turns to bolster not even the the
characters we've had at like tier two
but like the three and four every time
we cut to one of those characters I'm so
curious and the way it's building out
the world isn't just improving on the
boys but it's actually improving on this
show in real time like the idea of you
mentioned like the origin of someone
that would be susceptible to the seven
like it's building out that world again
the all really I'm we're going to point
out what Greg said I'm we're going to
pretend it's all right and I'm going not
even extra I'm just going to repeat it
with new words because of my brevity but
I like what do I think Greg Greg when
you cleaned up that dead body no but I I
love that uh it's not only clear but I I
mentioned the first episode it's kind of
like punching at everyone's like
worldview and I think that's really
important to have a show that saturies
our world from multiple pronged attacks
so the the boys is very good at
attacking politically and capitalism and
all those things but this is coming at
like parenting and Trauma and the way
people like abuse therapy and like the
way it's doing drug commentary bulimia
commentary cutting commentary what it's
like to come up in a world that feels so
big and this world is actually big so
what I love about comic books is there
at an 11 so if you have a morality story
it feels Larger than Life so it actually
feels more approachable the reason I've
always loved comic books is I've never
identified with religion because I've I
personally always considered religion a
fiction just my belief but with the
greatest comic book ever Jesus is such a
superhero for that world but with me
seeing it as fiction I've always liked
that these morality stories I know are
written by people to shape a fiction to
improve the world to improve our
morality to make us better but when you
make it so big it feels oddly more
approachable because you're like well if
they can do this large than life thing I
can do this thing and this show is
addressing that side of superhero lore
where it's where it's Peter Parker
having to overcome this bully and you
know that he's trying to not use his
powers and this is these kids you know
dealing with bulimia and cutting and
these things that so many people deal
with and and Trauma and depression and
anxiety and wanting to fit in but since
it's set in a superhero world it's more
approachable than just a cwen show so
whereas the first episode gave me this
great world that I was like oh this is a
great Gap show between the boys and I
love these characters I'm impressed this
is almost like this is hitting a
different Target demo a different
generation it might bring them into the
boys and it gives us I I joked but like
a year of the boys we get 10 weeks of
this we get you know the other show and
the whole time it's not the same
audience it's not the same goal it's not
trying to tell the same story and I you
know people get sick of me talking about
Comics but that's why I love them is
there's so many different versions like
when you read The Avengers that's
different than Justice League when you
read Spider-Man it's different than
Superman or Batman because there's so
many different ways to tell that story
and this is doing the do you like
Superman or do you like Batman with the
boys or do you like gen V and I'm just
so impressed it I it's great it is a
very impressive show it is very very
impressive uh they deal with a lot of
sensitive issues more sensitive I think
than what the boys like like again the
boys I think is very is very clever and
here this feels more personal because it
feels more intimate because like when
look at the
boys you're cutting around in many
different characters in many different
locations where here this is an mainly
an oncampus uh experience a very
intimate experience with these guys who
are all in the same Hub so I love The
Ensemble and it really does shine a
light on like especially with that
influencer moment of when they was
exposing the bulimia moment of it of uh
and like how
people Fain pain and um and and
exploit others in in a in a way of uh
posturing help yeah know like virtue
signaling is a buzzword that's used
wrong but that's virtue signaling like I
think it's great to address that like I
I I haven't read the comments yet on
what I said last week but people like oh
K doesn't like when they punch her BL
but I think it's really important to
address people using Progressive
ideology as a as a weapon and I think
it's important to show like social
justice being used negatively because
it's pandering for these companies
people and I love that they it it just
feels a part of the characters but
everyone has a a new no one has like a
villainous turn where it's just mustache
twirling you know even with the girl
when she was caught on her [__] uh
she you know they do stay with her for a
little bit like oh damn I messed up yeah
when it's like whatever you knew what
you were doing and even Golden Boy like
we got his yeah exactly yeah you get
that with Golden Boy my one concern like
I I love the idea because I think they
wanted you to kind of think of Starlight
like what it was it was something I was
saying in the in the first episode of
like yeah there qualities of her that
kind of remind you of Starlight um but
you could still feel Shad to something
different and then here they even make
the comment of like here's where she
becomes black Starlight or not right
yeah and I guess my one concern is the
Trope but in my but but then I'm like oh
but it could be a commentary on how
we've been getting like a like a Wanda
you know like a
villainous from hero to villain like
here's how you could really do it in a
way like I know you like I really love
Wanda and Multiverse and Madness but I
do agree with you on the thing you've
often complained about is that gap of a
transition from W division yeah and here
you get to witness that via the the
traumatic experience Tak advantage of
know and I think mean you could draw
some solid Scarlet Witch parallels the
red she was wearing but the way they
take are who's the who's the transgender
character the woman's played by London
Thor I went to acting school with that's
why I kept accidentally call and the
character is called Jordan Lee yeah
character Jordan Lee so Jordan Lee and
the way they've introduced Jordan Lee
and the way they introduced even um I
forget everyone's name John po polarity
PO is it Andre yeah Andre Anderson right
the way they've introduced Jordan Jordan
and
Andre at even at first you're like are
they going to be the bad guys right
right and then as the shows progress ing
you're seeing this flip R already within
the second episode where Marie is going
down a darker path and Andre like oh
maybe he's actually the protagonist yeah
he sacrificed things and she's getting
more isolated and vengeful yeah and then
Jordan is is someone you're like oh I
don't see Jordan as villainous at all
actually when when they kind of um set
them up to be that way in the first
episode so I think the way they play
with expectations versus whatever
realities are unfolding is really well
done I think the one thing semi working
against the show right now and and
granted we still got one more episode to
go before because they seemed pretty
intentional whenever they decide to
release three I know they did that for
season two was the first time they did
it and and it took it I was like yeah
you need the first three they did that
for season three when I didn't feel like
they needed it no and I think this could
have ended here and done two I think one
I honestly I think one was fine like you
could just ended on one um but you are
it's a new property exactly so I think
there is a justification to do three um
so before forming an opinion on it
I I'm very casually interested in the
mystery of the woods and stuff I think
we've just had such bigger um you know
Mysteries to unpack via compound V and
other things that we've done where this
does feel like the
most te mystery drama thing they are
unpacking the bo river river Wednesday
you know there's definitely some
Wednesday the basement it's got It's got
that quality to it where yeah but I like
how it's imbued in the character
development of it and yeah it's not some
nefarious clandestine thing it's about
his brother being there it's not like we
heard there's bad guys in the basement
that would be that very cheesy ECW
instead it's like my brother's trapped
in the basement caused my death right
now I'm I'm waiting to to see if if that
becomes more compelling I'd say cuz
right now that's weirdly I find
everything else super interesting and
that's the one part that we keep cutting
back to that I don't find myself itching
at what's going on there I'm hoping the
next episode puts it because I'm at like
a seven with the mystery and I'm at like
a nine and a half 10 with all the people
yeah that's funny you brought it up and
I was like yeah I'm so invested in just
the characters and and this immediate
Journey that like yeah the woods I'm
kind of like is is at the back of my
mind yeah cuz like the guy that was
running it's dead the guy that had
affected is dead so it's like I don't
really care about it I want to stay with
these alive people well and you know
that there are things like this lurking
and there's going to be some kind of
shadowy truth that's being hit like we
know that about this world now and Brink
is like you know our VA here but I love
that VA is the big overarching eagle
evil and I think we're going to see
those things come into play in the next
episode and I honestly think there's
going to be like a cliffhanger maybe
bigger than this that would be why they
did three oh yeah you got to but I I man
I I love that this is going to be weekly
cuz people will be talking about but I
do kind of wish it was just Warners yeah
I don't feel like the show is going to
pop off right away but I think like the
boys season one I think it has an
opportunity to really I think the word
of mouth on this is going to be
phenomenal it's so good and I mean I
know you both were uh trepidacious and
you weren't you know run I wasn't that
interested yeah like it was just like
it's fine and and I was really excited
so I love that it exceeded expectations
in two directions where they just put
homelander on the thumbnails for the
trailers I I would have been watching is
that not what we're going to do uh yeah
every thumbnail homelander Easter there
were frames of homelander we could put
authentically in this guys we got to be
the enemy that we're watching a
commentary on in order to profit off the
enemies that pay for this thing while we
watching on the enemies Network you know
it's part of it you guys the evil that
is YouTube Only extrapolated by the evil
that is Amazon that we were consuming
and then putting it on for you
capitalism at play here it's just it
trickles down the Nancy Reagan joke
maybe my favorite joke in the boys
history there was a Nancy Reagan BJ joke
that was the perfect it was plot driven
it furthered the narrative it was
exactly my kind of humor and F reaganism
I love that I'm so happy whoa don't
bring your wokeness to this w we need we
need to play middle up the aisle we need
to
attract cing Show episode one I said
something slightly anti-le so this week
I'm coming at re yes my hero I'm going
to change it every week yeah I'll be
like Jordan Lee switching there you go
you heard me yeah all right be fun to
edit Greg
oh the the reviews are just uncut no
like I I made a note to mute the there
number of words the letter B so oh
really yeah I make mental notes all the
time when we watch things uh all righty
guys I wonder if you'd have to be uncut
if you had like dense skin enough that
could be on fire I wonder if he didn't
have an option Golden Boy so you said it
was uncut I wonder could all righty guys
pack that real quick all right could he
be Serv we're gonna
we're going to take a little did Golden
Boy have a bris or not we might CH
clothes all right well thank you for
being here we'll see you guys soon y
Mark leech yes Mark oh you're in for it
Mark it's time for a chat GP shout out
all right John yes pick some categories
here okay give me your favorite movie
character uh any movie character James
Bond James Bond Perfect all right give
me your favorite um Beach uh Manhattan
Manhattan Beach uh who's your favorite
uh movie or TV show
Monster um the Baba Duke I guess the
Baba Duke okay uh give me a the the a
year
1957 all all right give me a um a
pronoun uh they all right give me um a
superla uh uh uh stupidest stupidest
give me
a
uh a superhero weapon um Boomerang
Boomerang okay uh a religion
um oh uh how's about scientology
Scientology okay a type of
Transportation skateboard
skateboard okay and
um an occupation um uh uh a bodybuilder
bodybuilder all right
sweet all right Mark all right Greg's
going to enter the magic words
okay all right um let me just uh oh wait
no I can't do that I gotta retype it
okay you can't double copy I have a
YouTube channel All Right Where I Need
to shout out a
patron his name is Mark leech yes we
call our patrons super sexy
reject write me a shout out um in under
let's say 60 words in the genre oh hey
spice it up yes in the genre of what
what's going be genre uh fantasy romance
in the in the RO in in the in the genre
of a
romance but
incorporate all of these a
words oh oh I'm so excited here we go
here we go sending sultry thanks to our
super sex sexy reject Mark leech imagine
James Bond skateboarding through 1957
Manhattan with a
boomerang en uh encountering the
mysterious babadook Mark they say it's
the stupidest most enchanting dance of
Scientology meets bodybuilder romance
ever witnessed your support is more
thrilling than than a spy mission and
for that our hearts Swoon for you oh my
God no human could create something this
good the machine understands romance
Mark does I'm touched right now and I
feel like we've grown closer together
just as a unit you know yeah as a as a
polyamorous relationship I think we're
all going to make it and it's all thanks
to chat GPT but more so thanks to you
mark leech thank you for being here
thank you for all of your many months of
unrequited love we'll catch you soon
catch you soon bud bud
[Music]
bud